child actors have delivered some of the
most surprising and impressive
performances in hollywood history but
just because you were great doesn't mean
you'll be in the next terminator movie
did you notice the absence of these
actors from their sequels
in 1991 filmmaker james cameron
unleashed terminator 2 judgment day the
action-packed follow-up to his
comparatively low-budget 80s sci-fi
thriller at the heart of the blockbuster
sequel is the father-son relationship
between a young john connor and arnold
schwarzenegger's robotic killing machine
from the future and if you want to shine
them on it's hasta la vista baby
hasta la vista baby
connor played by a young edward furlong
in his first film role is destined to
lead a revolution against skynet in the
future so it only made sense that
furlong would return to reprise the role
in subsequent sequels 12 years later
however terminator 3 rise of the
machines was released with actor nick
stahl stepping up as humanity's savior
despite being the appropriate age for
the role furlong was replaced when
production began during a public
appearance in 2019 the actor who
struggled with substance abuse for many
years told an audience i was part of the
project and had a very nice deal but
then i guess to celebrate i went out and
overdosed on coke and kind of destroyed
that whole thing t2 would not be the
last time audiences saw furlong as conor
however the release of terminator dark
fate in 2019 had him briefly return as
the character through the power of
d-aging technology
the saga of rocky balboa began in 1976
with the release of rocky which was
written by its star sylvester stallone
the story of a nobody getting his chance
to take on the biggest name in boxing
was such a colossal success that the
series is still going strong today ena
freed and rocky krakoff appear as rocky
jr and rocky iii and rocky iv
respectively but it's sage stallone's
betrayal of rocky's son in the fifth
film that is most worthy of note since
he was the actual son of sylvester
stallone 16 years after the film's
release the italian stallion returned in
rocky balboa although he was the right
age to return as robert sage stallone
declined to participate in the 2006 film
instead milo ventimiglia became the
fourth actor to play rocky's son as it
turned out sage declined the role to
focus on his career behind the scenes in
2006 the same year rocky balboa was
released sage directed the award-winning
short film vic sadly the younger
stallone passed away in 2012.
following the release of the
ill-received halloween three season of
the witch the halloween series was
rejuvenated with halloween for the
return of michael myers this time the
story focused on jamie lloyd who lives
with the foster family after the death
of her mother lori strode lloyd
portrayed by child actor danielle harris
returned the following year for
halloween five the revenge of michael
myers when the sixth film the curse of
michael myers was released in 1995 lloyd
was played by actress jc brandy instead
harris had planned on playing jaime
again but the producers originally
decided not to hire her because she was
just 17 years old at the time in a later
interview harris explained that the
producers wanted someone who was 18
freeing the production team to work more
hours on set consequently if she wanted
the role she would have had to become
emancipated surprisingly harris actually
agreed to go through this process only
to discover that the movie was turning
into something she didn't agree with one
particular meeting with producers about
the new script raised doubts about the
project in her mind harris explained i
remember leaving thinking oh these
people don't know halloween so i'm
pregnant with my uncle's baby like i
just didn't understand what had shifted
she was also told that her character
wasn't important enough to pay her the
salary she felt she deserved especially
after going through so many hurdles to
take the role in the first place in the
end she stepped away from the project
altogether
leonardo dicaprio has been very famous
for a very long time in 1997 he became a
superstar following the release of
titanic and he has worked steadily over
the years even winning an oscar for his
performance in 2015's the revenant but
one of his very first credits was a
horror movie 1991's critters 3 the third
installment of the cult horror series
from new line cinema dicaprio played the
stepson of the greedy landlord of a cd
apartment building in which the
protagonists of the film reside and less
than a year after the release of
critters 3 critters 4 was released but
this time without dicaprio dicaprio's
lack of involvement in the movie doesn't
appear to have anything to do with the
desire to recast the story simply didn't
allow for the inclusion of the character
from critters 3 as the narrative jumped
ahead to the year 2045. then again
dicaprio probably wasn't too devastated
about this considering he received his
first academy award nomination for
what's eating gilbert grape just two
years later
not only were the home alone movies
gigantic hit to the box office but the
first film released in 1990 also
launched its 10 year old lead into mega
stardom the little troublemaker with a
heart of gold and a penchant for
violence made macaulay culkin so famous
that he started popping up pretty much
everywhere oh mac here have a sprite
the staggering success of both home
alone and home alone 2 lost in new york
spurred production on a third movie and
in 1997 home alone 3 was released only
this time the spunky blonde kid
defending his home from criminals was
not played by culkin but by alex d lin's
culkin's absence can be explained by his
semi-retirement from acting in 1994. the
mid-90s were a particularly difficult
time in culkin's personal life and he
likely wanted to step away from the
limelight for a little while he does
still feature in movies and tv shows
every now and again but these days he's
much more selective about the parts he
plays
barrett oliver was our original gateway
to the magical world of fantasia in the
cult classic movie the never-ending
story it was his sympathetic portrayal
of the lonely bullied bookworm bastion
bucks that taught generations of
dreamers to always keep your imagination
alive when the sequel the never-ending
story 2 the next chapter was released in
1990 however there were a number of
casting changes including that of the
protagonist 90s star jonathan brandis
was cast as bastion for the follow-up as
with macaulay culkin it appears as
though oliver did not return because he
left acting behind in 1989 since then
the former child actor has devoted his
life to photography specializing in 19th
century camera processes
few young actors in the 1980s were as
charismatic and lovable as corey feldman
and his popularity was reflected in the
sheer number of roles he took throughout
that decade in the mid 80s feldman was
cast as the monster obsessed youth tommy
jarvis in friday the 13th the final
chapter the fourth film in the slasher
series tommy's peculiar love of masks
serves him well during the final
confrontation with the monolithic killer
jason voorhees as he uses his talent for
makeup to transform himself into jason
as a child confusing the killer long
enough to take him down the film's final
scene however hints at more to come for
tommy although the character would face
off with jason twice more feldman would
only play him in a brief cameo on friday
the 13th a new beginning during an
interview in 2011 he talked about his
experiences working on the fourth film
explaining how his commitment to the
goonies prevented him from starring in a
new beginning by the time friday the
13th part 6 jason lives was released the
character of tommy jarvis had aged up
making it difficult to bring feldman
back for the role
aliens the sequel to ridley scott's
classic 1979 space horror jumped forward
even further into the future dropping
sigourney weaver's alan ripley character
into a strange and lonely new world even
worse the aliens that killed her crew
have now infested a human colony on the
moon from the original film forcing
ripley to join a team of space marines
to investigate what happened it's here
that she meets newt a human survivor
living and hiding from the xenomorphs
we better get back because it'll be dark
soon and they mostly come at night
mostly
newt was played by 10 year old newcomer
carrie hen she had never acted before
and it appeared as though she had a
bright future in acting ahead of her
however the young actress decided to
leave show business shortly after
finishing the film deciding instead to
focus on just being a kid in 2019 she
told avp galaxy about why she made her
decision her father had been stationed
in england where aliens was filmed but
was later transferred to california now
that she lived in the states again she
briefly considered going back to acting
but decided against it she explained i
wanted to be a normal child and i'd
lived in england since i was about two
so it was quite a culture shock coming
back to the states and especially coming
back to california being in a well-known
film and speaking with an accent made
adjusting difficult but she persevered
and went on to accomplish her lifelong
goal of becoming a teacher something she
continues to do to this day
movie audiences met the werewolf
heartthrob jacob black in 2008's mega
smash hit twilight for many film goers
this was their introduction to actor
taylor lautner who would go on to star
in subsequent twilight films as well as
2011's abduction before becoming a
leading man however loutner had been the
co-lead of a wild superhero film for
kids called the adventures of sharkboy
and lava girl 3d
although this 2005 film wasn't exactly a
huge success it did get a spin-off in
the 2020 netflix film we can be heroes
the netflix follow-up features a brief
appearance from sharkboy and lavagirl
but only lava girl's original actor
taylor dooley returned to her role
sharkboy was instead played by stuntman
jeff dashnot who had long been a
frequent collaborator with writer
director robert rodriguez when speaking
to yahoo entertainment rodriguez said
there was no reason to bring lautner
back as sharkboy he explained i wouldn't
see sharkboy's face because i wanted him
to be more like batman there wasn't
enough to bring taylor lautner on he's
such a big star now and for him to not
have any dialogue and have his face
covered fans would be in an uproar
stanley kubrick's adaptation of stephen
king's novel the shining was released in
1980 and although it is now remembered
as a classic of the horror genre it
didn't set the world on fire right away
one of the film's major critics was
stephen king himself who disagreed with
kubrick's interpretation of his novel
the film has only grown in his steam
over the decades however and is now
widely considered a masterpiece king
released a sequel novel dr sleep in 2013
and in 2019 the sequel was adapted into
film by director mike flanagan who
envisioned it as both an adaptation of
king's novel and as a direct sequel to
the kubrick film while five-year-old
danny lloyd played danny torrance in
1980 he only returned for a brief cameo
as an unrelated character at a baseball
game in dr sleep instead ewan mcgregor
was selected to play the adult dany in
the sequel the reason for this was very
simple danny lloyd gave up acting years
ago talking to the guardian lloyd
discussed his life as a biology
professor in kentucky and his decision
to leave acting after years of
auditioning lloyd decided to call it
quits in the industry he explained i
wouldn't say it was upsetting but as i
got a little bit older it kind of got
boring lloyd is now a father of four and
holds no regrets about his decision
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]